amazon web services or aws a cloud
platform offered by amazon has become a
massive component of the e-commerce
business portfolio
last year it broke the record of 10
billion dollars of revenue which is
almost 13.5 percent of amazon's total
revenue
aws is a front turner to other cloud
computing platforms such as competitor
google or microsoft azure
but what exactly is aws
and why is it so popular these days so
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on what is aws
in this video we are going to cover all
the important concepts revolving around
cloud computing and aws
first we will have a quick introduction
to what is cloud computing
then we will understand what is aws
after which we will look around the
history of aws
then we will explore why is it so
popular
after which we will explore the
infrastructure and technology of aws
then we will figure out the benefits of
aws
followed by
some of the popular ews services
after which we will cover top companies
using aws these days
and at last we will discuss the future
of aws
so without doing further ado let's get
started with the video so what is cloud
computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
computing services via the internet
the cloud including servers storage
databases networking software analytics
and intelligence to provide faster
innovation in a more flexible resources
and economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost
run your infrastructure more efficiently
and scale as your business grows
now that we know what cloud computing is
let's understand the very important and
popular aspect of it
aws
what is aws
amazon web services or aws is a cloud
computing platform that manages and
maintains hardware and infrastructure
reducing the expense and complexity of
purchasing and running resources on site
for businesses and individuals
these resources are available for free
and for a fee per usage
it is a comprehensive and simple to use
computing platform offered by amazon
infrastructure such as service platform
as a service and package software as a
service are all used to build the
platform
now let's explore around the history of
aws
aws was first launched in 2004 and then
relaunched in 2006
after which aws benefited from a
relatively peaceful competitive
environment
allowing it to gain a significant
competitive advantage over current
competitors such as microsoft azure or
google cloud platform
however in recent years that market
share has been slipping slightly with
microsoft azure taking the lead
competition on the other hand is a good
thing and aws has momentum market share
profitability and some very talented
people on site
the innovation and customer focus are
greater than ever if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
but that raises a question of why is it
so popular
aws offers a diverse range of cloud
computing products and services
servers storage networking remote
computing email mobile development and
security are all services provided by
amazon's extremely successful sector
aws has considerably surpassed its
competitor in terms of size and
impressions in the computing world
did you know that in 2020 aws broke the
record of being a 10 billion business
so come let's go through the
infrastructure and technology of aws
aws operates globally in 25 regions
across six continents each region
consists of multiple availability zones
these are the physical data center where
computers reside
which are geographically isolated to
lessen the chances of a local tragedy
affecting a whole region
furthermore aws continent delivery
network has over 200 edge sites around
the world which is known as cdn
in addition to the publicly available
regions there are few special regions
the aws government cloud services
available in two regions for those
working in for the us government and in
china
there are two regions that are run by
local qualified firms in compliance with
chinese law and regulations
aws owns high speed fiber optic network
con connects all of these regions
availability zones and edge sites
aws has been developed its own hardware
to improve the speed and reliability of
its network
you're probably already familiar with
the aws network awx customers include
netflix twitch reddit slack and hulu
now that we know almost everything about
aws its infrastructure and technology
let's have a look at the benefits of aws
so following are the pros of using aws
services
aws enables enterprises to use
programming models operating systems
databases and architectures that they
are already familiar with
it's a low cost service that lets you
pay only for what you use with no
upfront fees or long time commitments
you will not have to pay for the
operation and maintenance of data
centers
it offers past deployments
and it is simple to increase or decrease
capacity
now let's explore some of the popular
aws services
here are some important cloud compute
services offered by amazon
ec2 or elastic compute cloud it is a
cloud-based virtual machine on which you
have complete control over the operating
system
this cloud server can be used at any
time
light sale
this cloud computing solution manages
and deploys the computer storage and
networking resources needed to execute
your applications
elastic beanstalk
this program allows for automated
resource deployment and provisioning
such as highly scalable production
website
eks elastic container service for
kubernetes this solution allows you to
run kubernetes or amazon's cloud without
having to install it
and aws lambda you can use this aws
service to run functions in the cloud
you can save a lot of money by using the
tool because you only pay when your
function works
so as we have covered so much about aws
let's move further and have a look at
the top companies using aws
instagram zoopla smugmug
pinterest
netflix and dropbox so
after all this discussion about aws
leads us to a question about the future
of aws
aws a highly configurable cloud
computing service provider has the
potential to be an error defining cloud
computing service provider
it has imagined an incredibly trusted
and rapidly developing cloud
infrastructure within its reach in a
short period of time
a leak that is rapidly growing and
dominating the computer and iit market
it is easy to predict the massive
transformation in cloud computing which
is dominated by aws based on these
defining parameters
unlike
its predecessors aws focus on the modern
markets affordability
customization and get what i want
dynamics
which proves it to have a very
progressive future in coming years
well this is all about aws we have
almost reached the end of this video if
i missed anything important do let me
know in the comments section i hope you
enjoyed this video on what is aws and
learn something new from it if you like
this video then please do hit the like
button thanks for watching this video
and stay tuned for more updates and
videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here